Yle Areena.
Ja sitten löytyä näitä nälkiintyneitä yksilöitä pitkin tuolla, koska ei enää lauma oo mukana, että saalista kiinni.
Nyt rupee tuleen Susi vahinkoja. Kiitoksia. Moi.
Moi, moi sinnekin, ja kiitos ensimmäiselle soittajalle.
Tästä alkoi tämänkertainen kansanradio.
On siis aika todeta perinteisesti, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan.
Puolituntisen ajatukset on ajoittanut tällä kertaa oikeille paikoilleen, koiviston lauri.
Yksi kansalainen toteaa, että paukut pois pennuilta, toinen taasen toivoo vähemmän räkää hiihtäjien naamalle,
niin ja eräs toteaa, että pannaan Moskova matalaksi.
Ja seuraavaksi kuulemme vähän radikaalimman mielipiteen.
Loppuvuotta kansanradion kuuntelijoille ja toimitukseen.
Taunoluuri alahurelle.
Aloitetaan nyt tämä vuosi tällaisella vähän saarikaalimalla mielipiteellä.
Elikä minulla on unelma.
Ei narkkareita Helsinkiin, ei narkkareita mennäkää.
Tähän tietysti päästään sillä, että estetään huumausaineiden tulo Suomeen.
No, se on tietysti, että sehän on vähän utopista ajatella, et ei huumausaineita tuu.
Mutta tästä tuloa se rarikaalisuus.
Elikä Suomest pitää ottaa käyttöön kuoleman tuomio näille, jopa tuo huumeita maahan ja jopa levittää niitä tänne.
Minä perustelen sitä sillä, että minä vertaan huumeiden salakuljettajia ja levittäjiä terrorista.
Sillä minusta, niillä ei ole ihmisarvoa, elikkä ne ei voi taas käyttää tätä kuoleman tuomiota.
Tämähän on hyvin verrallinen siihen, että joku terroristi räjäyttää jonkun panoksen tuolla ihmisjoukossa.
Mutta tämähän tietysti oi, että se ei tuu ihmisten näköön, tämä tuoraan maahan huumausaineita.
Nehän nyt sitten kuoloo sinne huumelualiinsa, ja miinkä ne nyt sitten nämä käyttää ja kuoloo.
Mutta se, että nämä ei oo ansaannu ihmisarvoa, jopa tuovat maahan huumeita ja levittää niitä täällä.
Se hän tuhuaa isoa joukkoja ihmisiä, eipä täs muuta. Hyvä loppuvuotta.
Kiitoksia, ja nyt palaamme pariin uutiseen, jotka tapahtuivat aivan viime vuoden lopulla.
Nimimerkki Paristoradio. Huomasin tuossa, että hallitusohjelmassa on, että Suomi siirtyi ensiasti digitaaliseen verkkoviestintään.
Mitenkähän se tämmösen, esimerkiksi analogiseen radion kautta viranomaisviestintä, jos sähköt esimerkiksi on poikki, niin odotetaanko niitäkin vaan digitaalisesti.
Ehkä hallitus elää jossain toisessa todellisuudessa, kun Suomessa toisessa päässä on monta päivää sähköt poikki. Kiitos, hei.
Hei, täällä edes mummo ihmettelee, että miksi ei sähkölinjojen vierestä kaadeta tarpeiks paljon noita puita, kun ne taas on semmosen ongelman saaneet aikaa, kun ne kaatuu niiden sähköjohtojen päälle.
Tuolis, että se silmän vääräisesti jo näkee, että mikä puu on nii lähellä, että se kahingoittaa lintioja, jos kaatuu päälle.
Tuolis, että edullisemmakskin nää kaataa nää puut, kun maana alle kaivaa niitä johtoja.
Va ei nyt tässä muuta, semmonen tuli mieleen, mutta varmaan sitä muutkin on ihmisellä. Heippa.
No, ku saivatko ohrusta päivää?
Päivää päivää.
No, semmonen asia tuossa äsken nishenkilö soitti, että Roanemella oli kaikki jumisellä, ei mikään ei pelannu näille matkustajalle asiakkale.
Tää harjutuu suomisella sillä tavalla, että yritykset ottaa rahat pois, kuten kaikki jolupuimpaa, mutta sitten jos pitäis jotakin saada korvata, ni sitten on kaikki hirviää vaikiaa. Siinähän menee herrojen optio, tuota ylisurret plakat kärsijää, kaikki. Tää näin oli ihan oikeassa, ku hän.
Tää lentokenttätilanteeseen.
Juuri näin, että kertoo näistä, että tuolla muualla olis pelannu, mutta Suomessa ei pelannu mikki. Se johtuu siitä, että piistettää, piistettää, piistettää, piistettää. Se on justi sana, että. Tää rahaa kyllä kelpaa otetaan kyllään pois.
Mitä mielestä tässä olisi pitänyt toimia?
No kuule, tuota, ei oo tätä niinku, jos tämmösiä ongelmia sattuu, ei ole koko tämä Fin aviattelma matkatoimisto, et nämä, nämä ei oo ollenkaan tuolta, tätä hommaa vienneet pitkään, että miten sitten toimii?
Jos pitää, ei sattuu jotakin tämmöstä.Ei, jos semmoista varajärjestelmää ei oo luotu, etää, tota, ihmisethän ei oo kuukalaisellakin lentokentällä nukkumaan siellä.
Ei oo niinku ollenkaan, koska se maksaa sen, enää isoja herroja optioita kärsivii, nii, nii, nii, tää nyt oo isommasta ralialo, totta, nii, siksi tota, tämä homma ei pelu.
Varaajärjestelmää ei oo semmoista, jos jotakin sattuis, kuten nytten saattaa.
Selainen pitäisi olla.Kiitoksia paljon tästä puhelusta, ja oikein hyvää.
Joo, tää muuten on hirviä hyvää, tämä kansan ralio, tää on todella hyvää, siis oikein tulee hyväälle suurelle, kuuntelempi tuota, noi, tätä, ja ihmisethän puhu asiaa.
Mukava kuulla, kiitoksia, ja…
Joo, se on ihan taivaan tosini, tuota… tuudethan ei pala tulessakaan nähestä sanottaa, nii, tuota, noi, ni…
Putta ei multa, ku tuoda, pietää pakkasia nyt, ja Oulussa on väheli kakskymmentä.
Kiitoksia, hei, hei.
Hyvä, kiitos, hei.
Talvissä teemoissa jatkamme ohjelmaa.
Enen puheluita yksi WhatsApp-viesti, aivan toisesta aiheesta.
Siinä vastataan yhdelle aiemmalle soittajalle, viestissä lukee näin.
Lonkeron värisen taivaan pohtialle.
Lonkeroon alkuperästi ginista ja greippimehusta valmistuu alkoholijuoma, joka on harmaata.
Eli lonkeron värinen taivas on harmaa.
Juomaa saa myös holittomana, sekä moneen makuun mausettuna, aina ananaksesta karpaloon. Kannattaa kokeilla.
Tällä tavoin, meille vinkkasivat, Tarja ja Veikko Nieminen lahesta, viesti oli lähetty WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta.
Meille Kansaradio voi lähteä WhatsApp-viestejä, sekä tällaisia tekstimuotoisia kommentteja, että myös ääniviestejä.
Kansaradion WhatsApp-numeroon 044 551 54 64.
Lonkeroon ja tietämätön, etävä pohjampaa, ihmettelee tällasta aliaa, elokapina istustelee keskellä helmin teipä, ja kapinoi kaiken maaliman huuhaata vastaa.
Empä oon yhtää kertaanään, heitä pistää, sopamatta, istumatta, mihinä olis luonnollinen paikka, huojella, tätä luontoa, koska mereen lykätään edelleen aivan valtava määrä.
Käteen lonta, typpin Helsinkiä, ja, ymmärrättekö, kuinka paljon se lumi sisältää miitankua mikromuossa?
Siel on lähtää, uusneli on autopatisiä, joita talattikin natkottelee, etkä siinäpä, ehrettelimetta luonnoa suojelijoille, tahteruvaa, eipä he.
Laika täällä, taas kerran, nytko on tullu lonta?
Ja vanhat ihmiset ei jaksa tehdä lumi töitä, ni jos sul on naapurissa joku ikäihminen, ni mene ihmeissä jelpaamaan.
Jos sulla itelläs ei oo lumikoloa, ni kyllä tällä naapurilla varmaan on.
Mulla on onneks niin ihana poika, että hän tulee aina, jos lonta tulee, ni aina auttamaan mua.
Ja mä toivon hyvää vuodenjatko, kyllähän se lumi mukava oo, mutta ei liikaa oo liikaa.
Hei, hei.
Avantokelluja tässä päivää.
Pieni runonpätkä.
Kaksi tunnettua baristaa, mopoillaansa ajaa, päristää.
Toista vähän närästää, kun ohjaustanko täristää.
Toista vaivaa, nuha, hän on juha.
Ei tuoksu mokka, on tukossa nokka, pysähtyvät.
Toinen nenässä niistää, toista viluviistää.
Yhdessä toteavat, ei tule hyvää kahvia, jos suodatin on pahvia.
Tämän kahvisen runon jälkeen meillä on luvassa uuteen vuoteen liittyviä ajatuksia.
Enen puheluita vielä yksi postikortti, siinä lukee seuraavasti.
Hyvää uutta vuotta, nimittäin yleisradion satavuotisjuhlavuotta.
Itse pidän yleä lahjumattomimpana ja luotettavimpana tiedon välittäjänä.
Olette ihan parhaita.
Voi etta.
Tällä tavoin meille kirjoitti postikortissaan Tarmo Vantaalta.
Kortin kuvassa on luminan maisema, jossa aidasta roikkuu lyhty.
Kiitos sinulle, Tarmo, näistä sanoistasi.
Meille Kansanradioon voi lähteä kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen.
Kansanradio, PL, 79, 000, 24, yleisradio.
Nimimerkki paukuttelut pois pennulta.
Himettelee sitä, että mikä siinä on, että annetaan akaroille paukut kätteen.
Ja ne ampuu niitä paukkuja sitten jo ennen uuden vuoden aattoa jo, monta päivää ennen sitä, ja sitten kaikki kistat ja koirat peleikää sitä aina.
Paukuttelu on sallittu vain uuden vuoden aattona kello 18-yölle kahtee asti.
Mikä sinä on, ko ei, tajuuta.
Se on lain mukaan kiellettyä kaikena muuna aikana, se paukuttelu, ja alaikäsiltä se on myös kiellettyä.
Orpo ja purra, tehkää asialle jotain.
No, helpottiko nyt sai tämä asian sanotta?
Ei mulla muuta, moikka.
Virva täällä.
Moi, minä vieti nuutta luotta kärnstelmällä sedeitäni, ja siipoamalla sede yllyjä, ja minun suosikki artisteani, mitä sedeistä löytyi, ja heiä pisi sillä lailla, että aina kun haluan kuilea suosikki artisteani, niin löydän heti.
Minulla on paljon sedeitä, ja muutama suosikki artisti, minulla on jopa, appa, kystyän sede, ja kaksi, jari sillanpää sedeitä, ja monta, soi muuta, artisti, muitten artistien sedeitä.
Ei, olen onnellinen, osaa minullaan.
Ma, mo, on, paljon, omaa musaa, kiitos, hei.
No, se oo jokisamppa täältä ähteristä tervee.
Kaina sama laulu joka vuos.
Hilo tuli teet kiellettävä tarpeettomana.
Kansarasalotessa ai nii menet täyteen alle viikossa.
No, jos ne kielletää, niin sitten porukka keksii jotain muuta, tekee ite jotkut, pommisat, tai jotai, vielä vaarallisempaa.
Täällä ei tee lohku ampuu oikee.
Velma ois tää mieltä, ei näitä piekkieltää.
Hyvä kansaradioystävät, tääl on mamma täältä Turun seudulta, tai olin hiljakkoimasta tänne muuttanut, metsä tosää näkyjä.
Jotenki ajatteleman, mä jäikö, toi presidentti piti, et se puhe saa tämmösenki sanan, että, missä Suomi on, missä tilassa.
Sanotte, murrokseessa, et, mitä se murrokse se nyt oikein tarkoittaa.
Ni, mä ei kyllä, olen sen samaan kyllä kuullut, mutta en tässä yhtämmöisessä yhteydessä.
Et tää tarkoittaa, toi Suomi on jollain tapa, että luntaa on edestä paljon, samoin takana, ettei pääse kumpaankaan suuntaa hyvin.
Kukaanhan täällä kansaradioihmistä voisi, tämä ei kertoa, kun kansaradioissa tiedetään kaikkea, kaikista kaikkea.
Ois mukava kuulla, että, mitä tää nyt tarkoittaa, että, onks se vakavaa, vai ihan vaan, muuten vaan sanottu?
No, sen kuulee sitten, kun taas suun luntaina tuo kansaradio tulee.
Minä kuuntelen sitä tarkkaan. No, tämmösti ja hyvä, tätä vuoden jatkoa vaan.
Onkai tää hyvä, tämä kippuosi.
Hyvin samalla aiheella jatkaa seuraavakin kansalainen.
Nyt kuitenkin laajennetaan teemaa kotimaasta maailman politiikan pelikentälle.
No, nii, Mauno Jouto, voutilainen, nyvästylän, kelan suunnasta, kun soittelee, kuten ehkä joku saattaa, vähän sitä tunnistaa, niin Tupilta oli oikein asiaa, tämä uuden vuoden puhe, kehitys on tärkeä, ja kehityksen panostaminen, tämä tuotiin hyvin esille.
Nytenköhän tämä diktaattori Putinin uuden vuoden puhe, en nyt ole koko puhetta nähnyt suomenusta, kun Venäjän kieltä osaan lähinnä vain tuon rukiverja rastui tavarit, ja harasoi, ja potka, ja potka, niin tuota, tämä asia.
Juvan tämä hirmu, niin tämä Ano Turtijäinen, onko diktaattori Putin maininnut puheessaan, tai muuten, tai mainittimassa, että miten Kiitoli ja Venäjälä ovat, kun ovat saaneet tämän Juvan ihmeen tuota vierakseen, ja miten Juvalla kärsivätkö he menetyksestä, kun ovat tämän arteen menettäneet tai menettämässä, tai ainakin nyt siltä näyttää.
Niin, onko tästä minkälaisia lausuntoja, kiitoksia, ja ehkä asiaan saadaan selbyttä. Hyvää sunnuntain ja vuoden ratkoa kaikille, kiitoksia.
Joo, Virho täällä. No se Putini antoi nyt terveisiä, taasko kaapelit meni rihti, Viroin ja Suomen välillä. Se oli joululaheva Putinilta Suomelle, ja Virolle, ja Euroopalle.
Mutta tämä sotahan loppos siihen, ku annetaan vain pitkän matkan ohjukset, jotka ylettyy Moskovaan.
Se on viikossa oittama sotaa, mitä te te Euroopaa herrat pelkkätte siellä.
Ei sitä atomia tarvitse pelätä, Putinia toomia, ohan sitä Euroopassakin atomia.
Ei moota, ku annetaan torvet soimaa, jopa Nampe. Moskova, matalaksi.
Tääl on paskat, hoosusses, Euroopaa herrat. Ei olis uskannu, miten wellihousuja te olutta. Heppa.
Ni me merkii rauhanturva, ja.Ei sitä Putini saa vastuuseen teoistaa, koska.
Tuntuu vaan, et se pierskelee saa punkkerissa. Se pitäis saa olla esiin, ja pitää pistää tuomioistamme eteen, vastaamaan teoistaa.
Muutsais oikee.Ei se ole pierskelepaa siellä, ette, nyt hän ei teen mitää.
Hän, jos sä ois punkkeessa pierskeleittää, mut puutti me saada vastuuseen rumpistaa.
He pitäis, he pitää, saa tuomioistamme eteen, ja, tuo mitä vankivaa. Se ois oikee.
Noo, tas on vaan Jormavaarimiete, tästä maailman menosta, ja.
Oli aika ovella vetos rumpilta, ottaa ja päästää, loputkin Pohjoismaat NATOon.
Nyt on hyvä rokottaa ja ottaa Tanskan hallinnonma Grönlandi haltuunsa.
Mutta, mitä tekee Suomi? Myökkäilee hyväksyvästi, ja juuri on puhuttu Pohjoismaiden yhteisestä puolustuksesta ja sen tärkeydestä.
Mutta, ku te laulussakin sanotaan, sen lauluja laulat, jonka joukossa seisot. Kiitos.
Onko Trumpin pelko Viisauren alku? Näin käsittää maailma tällä hetkellä.
Kyllä on mennyt mallihin, ku yks kauhukakara pompottaa koko maailmaa, ja luuloo, että saa tehdä ihan mitä haluu.
Seuraavaksi on aika pysähtyä sotekommenttien pariin, ennä niitä puheluita yksi sähköposti kotimaan politiikasta.
Olen uskonut, että hallitus ja eduskunta hoitaa ydessään maamme asioita parhailla mahdollisella tavalla, mutta eihän se niin ole.
Vaan oppositio koettaa jarruttaa kaikessa ja hankaloittaa koko eduskunnan työskentelyä.
Sielä haukutaan ja jäkätetään, ja lyödään hanttiin asiassa kuin asiassa, olisiko jonkinlainen käytöstapa koulutustarpeen ja soveltuvuuskoulutus.
Näin päätti sähköpostisaniimemerkki tympääntynyt edustajien riitelyyn.
Kansanradion sähköpostiosäite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Ihmettinen sellaista, kun tota ihmistä ei saa millää hoitoa.
Se tekee kaikennäköstä, siitä huolimatta, sitä ei saa mitenkää hoitoa.
Asiantuntijat sanovat, et se pitäis saada hoitoa.
Sitä ei saas hoitoa.
Tää on aika erikoista Suomessa, että ihminen pitäis saada psykiatrisee hoitoa.
Sitä huolimatta, siel on niin iso itsemäärämisoikeus, et sit ei saa hoitoa millää.
Eli, toivottavasti joku kansanedustaja kuuntelee tätä, tai joku puolueen muu ihminen kuuntelee, ja pikaisesti korjaa tämän itsemäärämisoikeuden.
Et ihminen, mitä tarvitsee psykiatrista hoitoa, ni sen sais sinne helpommin. Mut ei oo mitää muuta.
Tää on pakkarajalta, terve.
Terve, terve.
No, sen verran haluaisi tossa, kun tämmönen mahdollisuus, että pystyy soittamaan tähän teille, nii.
Mää oon tota nii, A.V.H. potilas, jos tiedät, mitä tarvita, Toipilas potilas.
Eli, A.V.H. potilas.
Eli, a.V.H. potilas.
Joo.
Eli, a.V. potilas.
potilas.
Pilas.
Eli, a.V.H. potilas.
Eli, a.V. potilas.
Potilas.
Poikki, että tämmöstä tällä kertaa, hei, hei.
Siellä oli tämmöstä. Meillä kansanradiossa on seuraavaksi luvassa lapsia ja nuoria koskevia puheluita.
Enen niitä kerron, että kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan, joka perjantai kello 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilaat olemasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
No, Lassi täältä, Helsingin alppiariosta.
Ajättee vaan sanoa semmosen asion, kun törmäsi semmoseen ikävään tilanteeseen, että olin Inva Vesterson, sitä potkisti.
Tullessani ulos, nii oli pikku kakaroita.
En tiedä, mistä päin heidän vanhempansa oli lähtöisin, mutta he huusivat, että me ovan maahanmuuttajia.
Sanoin heille, että sitä suuremmaa syyllä heidän pitäis kunnioittaa meitä suomalaisia.
Ja, jos tällaista jatkuu, niin minun nähdäkseni, juuri sen takia, maahanmuuttajia kaikkia moititaan.
Siedän, kyllä, et oon asialle jätti maahanmuuttajia, mutta muistakseni Koranista sanotaan näin:
Poista, samoin kuin Raamatusta, että poista paha keskuuresta, että näiden pitäis alkaa opettamaan näille jälkeläisilleen täytöstapoja, etätuolet, ja riehumisia potkimisia, varsinkaan.
Minä itse invaliseudun jo 22, vasempaan jalkaan, joka on pahempi vamma.
Oikeaan jalkaan tuli kaksi ja puol vuotta myöhemmin veritulppaa.
Sen takia minulla on rollahtori.
Mutta kädistäni minä oon erittä etelästä kunnosta, että jos oisät tuu kätteni ulottuvilleni.
Kuri, kuria oistuu, ei muuta, morjei.
No nii, Pohjois-satakunnassa vaan, hyvää päivää.
Hyvää päivää.
Juu, soittelen, ihanko katton tota maailman menoa, ja sillain ikko Suomestkin, ni yhden asian mä sanoisin,
en mä nyt mitään ne bokkeutään, mutta paljon johtuu siitä, ettei lapsia synny.
Kaikkiä asioita yritetään, taloutta nostaa ja työpaikkoja, ei se onnittu, perheet pitäis saada isommat.
Mikä olisi mielestäsi hyvä koko perheelle?
No, en mä nyt sano, meillä on itsellä viis lasta, ja kaikilla on sitten jo lastenlapsia.
Lometoista lastenlasta oi, ja niillä on jo kavereita, että jouluna meillä oli kaksimata henkeä vähän päälle,
ja sitten joulupäivänä tuli dia ykstoista, ku siellä on sitten jo lastenlapsilla niitä kavereita.
Ja, siitä mä olen iloinen, että nuorilla on kavereita.
Joo, teillä mahtuu pirtiista, tämmö isompikin porukkaa.
No juu, kyllä meillä sillain, ei mikään oman kotitalossa asuttaa,
tää on jo nuorman poijan, tää talokikko, meillä ei enää mobiilista kää oo.
Ja, se on niinko jollakin lailla väärä käsitys mennyt tosta perheistä sillain, että vaimotki töisi.
Aha.
Ko, siinä on semmoinen asia, että munkin vaimo oli töis, vanhain koris oli, ja olis tykännyt olemaan,
mutta meillä oli kolmea puolihettaaria maata, ja laitettiin, haluttiin yrittäjäks.
Vaimo tuli kotihoitoon karjaa, meillä oli silloin, ja mä tein kauppoa, joko seittötä kolmen mä oon alkaanu, kulukukauppalupa tuli, ja päräkkoreja myinko.
Mut siis mielestäsikö niin, että perheestä vaan yksi vanempi, toinen vanemista vaan kävisi töissä?
Niin, ja kato se tuo, lapset hoidetaan kotona, se on arvokasta työtä, koska siitä maksetaan.
Sitten palkkako, sä viet sen tonne, mutta sun täytyy viedä se, hoitoa se, sinne, ja hakee se, siinä menee aikoa, maksettais jonkun moinen palkkakotio.
Kerron vielä tähän loppuun, että mitä se erityisesti ratkaisisi, jos perheet olisivat isompia?
Kyläpää, monta asioa, vaikka urheilu, ne vähenee, ei oo maaseudulla väke, ja pohjoiseskin vähenee, ei tuenää niitä kovia urheilijoita, jotka sai kotona harjoitella,
ja sitten tyrittäjähkä sanon sen, että pankijohtaja minulle antoi nevon.
See, sinä, Heikki, se hannikotio, älä lähden minkään keskustoa.
Mä olin aina siinä apuna, ko pienet pellot oli, meilläki ei ollut lehmilä vaitumia melodit.
Kaks lehreä ostettiin estii, ja siitä harjettiin, ja kyntos varjonyi, ja hyvää, tätä vuoden loppuu.
Kiitos, kaikkea hyvää sinne pohjoisestakuntaan.
Kiitos, kiitos. Hei, hei.
Joo, Tapsa, morjes. Ihan pitää kertoa, että tästä, kun puhutaan nuorten pahoinvoinista ja siihen liittyvistä ongelmista, niin jollakin tavalla minusta tuntuu, että nyt on kodin rooli unohtettu kokona.
Se olen 77V, ja kyllä koen, että koti on se kasvattaja, ja kodista tulee sitä rakkautta, välittämistä, huolenpitoa, ynnä muuta hyvään elämään liittyviä arvoja, niin niitä tulee sieltä kotoa, ja jos nämä asiat ei toimi, niin meidän lapset ovat varmaa enemmän surullisia kuin onnellisia.
Tällainen mielipide, morjes.
Nyt kun alkaa hiihto kilpailu taas telkkarissa, niin olis ihana katsella niitä, mutta mua inhottaa se räkä, mikä niillä roikkuu polviin saakka.
Nyt kun niille voi tehdä niitä irtohihoja niihin puseroihin, vaikka flanellista, ja ne sais maaliin tullessa vähän siipata sitä naamaansa, niin olis mukava katsella.
Kiitos, ei.
Nimemerkki, urheilu, fani.
Kumma, sitä vaan, että valmentaja korreilee Suomessa aika huonosti. Se, että, jos valmentaja saa potkuu, niin siitä tehdää iso numero. Siitä kaikki saa tietää, musti se on huono asia, musti se on seuraaja valmenta yksyys asia.
Ei, se pitäisi nii iso numero tehä.
Nyt tilanne on se, että on aika kuunnella monipuolinen kattauskommentoja edellisten ohjelmien ajatuksiin.
Aloitaan aihe viestillä, joka on lähetty kansaradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Mieskuuntelija ilmaisi kansarion lähettämässään kannanotossa näkemyksen, ettei metsässä pidä morjenstella. Olen hänen kanssaan täysin samaa mieltä.
Hoidetussa talousmetsässä, jossain sivummalla, saa yleensä melko rauhassa nauttia jokaisen oikeuksista, mutta jos mieltää metsäksi vaikka kaupunkimetsän tai kansallispuiston, niin ainahan siellä on joku yltiö sosiaalinen häiriköimässä.
Poikkeushetkiä, joissa hyväksyn metsässä tuntemattomille jaarittelun, ovat hätätapaukset, ja tilanne, joissa jokaisen oikeuksia hyödyntävä eksyy metsässä olevan talon tai mökin pihapiiriin, jossa on asukkaita paikalla.
Valmius puheyhteyteen osoittaa, ettei vieras ole pahanteossa tai etsimässä varastettavaa.
Tämä teksti oli lähetetty kansaradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella. Sen oli kirjoittan nymerkki "Kuuntelija".
Marjatota täältä Vantaalta. Mä olisin sanonut siihen, kun se yks nainen tänään kertoo, että kuinka tossa luonto-ohjelmien taustallani soi sitä musiikkia.
Ku monta kertaa on nii kaunista luonto-ohjelmaa, katsottava, ja sitten kuitenki siellä soi semmoinen murja tota, varmaan teknilisesti tehty musiikki taustallani, se kyllä häiritsee.
Mä oon jopa laittanut joskus kiinni nii ton television tai radion, kun en oo jaksanu kuunnella sitä musiikkia, kun mielellään katsois niitä ohjelmia.
Ei mulla tässä muuta, että kiitos vaan, hei.
Jo, Markku, on täältä. Hyvä vuodenjatkoa, kansanradiotervehtiminen tuolla lenkkipolulla tai kävyen liikenteen väylillä, varmaan tässä vuodenvaihteen, uuden vuoden aloittaessa toimintaansa.
Me on must ihan asialista, että moikkaillaan, koska, mitä maailman poliittinen tilanne kaikkinen saa, on vähän, tekee nöyräksi, ja jos nyt haluaa sitten, että hymy olisi riittävää, niin se on yhtä arvokas.
Kyllä moikkaaminen on ihan kivaa ja voi jäädä vaikka vähän jutustelemaan, jos ei muuta, niin, jos vastaantulijalla on koira, niin vaikka jutella sen koiran kanssa.
Tää on molemmin puolista vuorovaikuttamista, joita nyt kannattais vaalia, mut hyvä puhevuoro. Kiitos, Vulemin.
Sitä lanttuloorasta, mä oon aivan samaa mieltä, kun edellinen soittaja. Minä ehdottaisin, että lanttu laitetään.
Tais paloihin esikäytettynä, vaatikko on semmosee, minkä voi laittaa uuniin, tai sitten laittaa pannoon.
Mutta semmoinen lanttuloora ei oo mistää kotoisiko, se oo vetine, eikä maistu miltää, mitä nykyisin on.
Ja täytyis olla enemmän niinku lanttupitoinen.
Sitten näistä jouluruuista, niin kyllä on joulun jälkeen kinkku, tietysti on aivan ihana, ja hernekeitto, ja sitten on joulutortut.
Kyllä jouluruuat on Suomessa aika hyviä, ainakin suomalaisen mielestä.
Hernekeittokin on erittäin hyvää, siihen voi niitä kinkkupaloja sitten laittaa, jotka on vähän kuivunut.
Kaikki on jouluruoka, herkulista, lanttulaatikko ja perulaatikko, nertuppaa ole vähän semmosia, että niitä vois vähän uusia.
Eipä tässä muuta, kiitos vaan, ja hyvää, vuodenjatkoa, 26.
Aivan pian on tutun runoilijan vuoro.
Häntä ennen kerron vielä kansanradion puhelinnumeron.
Se on 08 001 54 64.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton.
Ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12:30 alkaen, tuo samarossa vastaa ihmis vastaaja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Hei, täällä Aarolaste.
Kansanohjelma.
Ei erojen eikä myöskään narrien, vaan ihanien, reilujen ihmisten, joista osa aina ohjelmaa valmistaa.
Lasfe ja Lauri hienosti valmiiksi saa.
Heidän mainion työn jälki näkyy.
Monek kiittää, miten asiat yhdistyy.
Kansanradiossa suosio hyvin suuri.
Hyvä tekijät, ohjelmaa, hyvä tuu.
Tiedämme, mitä maamme makaa.
Kansa viikostaen tietoja jakaa.
Tekijöiden vuoden vaikea työ.
Parhaan ohjelman mönekeilyö.
Suurta suuremmat idokset siitä.
Sama lainen, uuteen vuoteen liite.
Sitä lastelta ja Laurilta toivota.
Myös hyvää uutta vuotta ja kaikkea hyvää heille toivota.
Ja tietysti Aarolaste toivoo kaikille, koko kansalle hyvää uutta vuotta.
Kivaa uuttamatta, vieluita uuttamatta.
Kaikkiä silvaa, huutta.
Vielä ainakin kuulemme ehdotuksen uudeksi elokuvaksi.
Ennen viimeisiä puheluita minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää.
Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa.
Kansanradio, jälleen viikon päästä.
Olen Kirsti, ja olen nainen.
Ja se tarkoittaa sitä, että minä olin nainen. Minä saan arvosta.
Minäpäs arvostelen ensin nainen.
Ko ne on jossakin realiteettisarjassa ja meren rannoilla ni.
On nii pienet halsut, etteikko näytä takkaa enää ollenkaan ni lois olisia.
Ja saanan mi arvostella miehet.
Niel on nii rumaapa.
Miten se onki? Niille soi yhtää sepa.
Ja sitten on ne hiuksekki. On, miten ta?
Nytkö mie arvostelin? Minua ei saa arvostella ainakaan sosialista mediata, sillä minä olen nainen.
No, se hirveää halua, ja kaikki minua puolustaa, ettei Kirstinkin puu saa käyä.
Vot se on nainen, ja naisia ei saa sortaa.
Emmosta juttua. Kiitos, että olen nainen.
Alokaupungi Mettakulma jätkäpäivää, vuotta 26.
Nyt ois korkea aikaa kikarismää tehdä Suomesta elokuvaa Suomi ennen, ja nyt EU:ssa, miksi tämä muu?
Ja kaikki alkais ymmärtää, miten tyylmästi kehityskul.
Ja muistakaa, Paavo Väyrynä ei ole poistunut, tästä yhtäskulahan on vielä vaikutusvaltainen terve.
Ei, kansanradio, hyvää uutta vuotta, kansalaiset, toivottaa kansalainen.
No, hyvää huomenta päivää, hyvää uutta vuotta, onnellisempaa, mikä viime vuosi, mutta reellisesti arvioin, että siitä tulee vielä paskempi, ainakin pieneläkeläisille, hyvää päiväjatkoa ja vuodenjatkoa.